middle-earth is got its mojo back know a
really good movie superior to the first
in that it brings its characters to
rambunctious life no it's a ride well
worth taking knew the desolation of
smaug has been touted as a major
improvement upon the first installment
of The Hobbit series an unexpected
journey which was utter so I went
to go buy my tickets with moderate hopes
for a good time what I got was a pile of
poop
I'm a bit of a tokine superfan so it
hurts particularly badly when someone
takes millions of dollars and makes a
hollow spectacle of his work The Hobbit
isn't the high-water mark of the tokine
Irv robe but it is still an exciting and
wonderful book it's also a small
self-contained book one written without
the knowledge that a vast important
masterpiece of the fantasy genre would
follow it or even be connected to it The
Hobbit is tokine flexing his muscles
with fairy story only later when the
Lord of the Rings began to take shape in
his mind did he realize that it could
serve as a prequel backstory of The Lord
of the Rings for a deeper taste of the
tokine legendarium take a look at The
Silmarillion or the book of unfinished
tales The Hobbit is essentially a
repurposed standalone novel replete with
a number of beasts and monsters that
never again make an appearance in
middle-earth so why does Peter Jackson
feel the need to bloat The Hobbit into
seven and a half hours of extravaganza
and spot-welded to the Lord of the Rings
unfortunately I think this is because a
straight telling of The Hobbit would
feel anticlimactic even now all I can
think of is how inconsequential The
Hobbit tale is compared to what is about
to follow so Jackson has to inject as
much epicness as he can into the story
but when combined with the goofy poorly
acted comedy of the doors the whole
thing just feels like a big mess part of
this is prequel blues I'm hard-pressed
to remember any cinematic prequel that
actually improves upon the story that it
proceeds if you can think of one write
it in the comments but most of the time
they lean on something that I call pre
weight objects or people or event that
we're meant to recognize from the
original story or elsewhere in history
and go ooh oh my god it's the Prancing
Pony I remember that from the lore of
the rain free weight can be used to
incredible effect
but the Hobbit uses it as a crutch just
like the Star Wars prequels did in the
end Jackson doesn't do himself many
favors 48 frames per second for example
is a mistake the lighting looks
artificial the costumes and facial hair
are shoddily done there's not a single
line of dialogue that isn't predictable
Gandalf is relegated to an expositional
role no one surprises most disappoint
the action is silly and void of drama
the dragon bye bye bye yeah I get it
Evangeline Lilly sucks almost as much as
the dwarf she falls in love with in all
five hours of the first two Hobbit films
can't equal the emotional content of
these two deleted minutes from the two
towers symbol Munna
ever has it grown on the tombs of my
forebears
now it shall cover the grave of my son
alas that these evil days should be mine
the young perish and the old linka
but I should live to see the last days
of my house
Sandra's death was not of your making
no parent should have to bury that child
you
he was strong in life his spirit will
find its way to the floors of your
father
or stolen
let's assume fast